what would 26 year-olds say to 16 year
old Niall now about the ways life's
turned out your life's about to change
ridiculous amounts you're gonna go from
living in a small town of about 30,000
people to living in the biggest cities
in the world and you're going to play
stadiums all over the planet in Agra we
weren't the biggest boy bands of all
time Niall Horan really took us down
memory lane Thursday night during the
Late Late shows latest installment of
carpool karaoke talking so much one
direction that my heart basically burst
out of my chest
it was huge like I think you know you've
made it when you just start having all
manner of products yeah and things just
known about you like my favorite of the
1d merchandise was the One Direction
toothpaste the fresh mint toothpaste
yeah
there were fluoride toothpaste fresh
mint and I actually brushed my teeth
with that every day 17 fillings that
wasn't even the best moment though Niall
also dropped this bombshell do you
actually think one direction will get
back together yes whoo yes seriously
he said that do you actually think one
direction will get back together yes
yeah I'm gonna need a minute
oh and there's more haven't look at 1d
from the outside now I got to see like
how big it was
yeah it's only looking back now I
realize how lucky we were like there was
no one doing stadiums at the time yeah
it's just insane a One Direction reunion
could actually happen let's review the
facts shall we
seems some of the guys are still friends
you mentioned Niall he's on stage right
now how has it been reuniting with him
on the jingle balls war I mean we played
a bit of PlayStation is thing in my
hotel room in San Jose he came hung out
for a little bit but it's just so nice
to see him and I mean I don't know when
you see someone they haven't seen for
ages and you become the same person you
were when you with I don't know it's
very interesting you recently said you
ran into Harry Styles for the first time
in three years at the capital Jingle
Bell Ball in London what was the nature
of your conversation that night um we
spoke about a number of things so it was
good to see him he was pretty much the
same boy that I left him we spoke about
the kids and happiness and all sorts and
Harry Styles said this pretty recently
what's your guilty pleasure walking out
to one direction
the biggest question would be whether or
not Zayn Malik would be on board
Harry kinda took a dig at him on SNL
last year I love those guys they're my
brothers
[Music]
Ringo what was your reaction to Harry
Styles calling Zayn Malik Ringo during
his SNL monologue last one I think you
know I think it's just a funny joke at
the end of the day I mean obviously you
know Zane's circumstances for leaving
were his own and it's a different
situation for all of us I suppose we
deal with it in a different way so I
mean I thought was quite funny it was
pretty funny
alright guys that's it for today here's
to hoping for a One Direction reunion
one day for all the latest on 1d stick
with ET until next time I'm Katie Krauss
and bye for now
[Music]